Tristan and I are having another baby
it's supposed to be a really exciting
time and it's just a different
experience Khloe Kardashian not exactly
feeling baby bliss amid Tristan
Thompson's cheating scandal I think it's
important to show people you can turn
your life around you can go through hell
and high water but you can still come
out and have a beautiful positive happy
life and that couldn't be truer for Coco
which we see in a new teaser for the
Kardashians season two there is
something that I'm ready to talk about
Tristan and I are having another baby
it's supposed to be a really exciting
time and it's just a different
experience it's hard to watch her in
pain this has been a difficult time in
my life but it's the start of something
positive and happy and beautiful yeah
clearly wasn't easy for Chloe or her mom
Kris Jenner to deal with the NBA star's
betrayal I'm not sure that there's one
thing that hurts more than the other in
a situation like this to understand we
gotta run down a quick timeline in
December news broke of Tristan's latest
cheating scandal where he fathered a
child with another woman the Scandal
played out on season one of the
Kardashians everything is an act of
betrayal everything is a lie everything
is manipulation it's deceit to Tristan
have every opportunity to tell me yes
was Tristan going to tell me if there
wasn't a baby involved absolutely not at
the time the public had no idea Tristan
and Chloe were expecting baby number two
but in July Chloe's rep confirmed the
news to E.T and revealed the surrogate
was implanted in November just one month
before Tristan's cheating scandal
erupted and that shows a lot about his
character the entire thing is Despicable
Chloe and Tristan welcomed their second
child together a baby boy earlier this
year and season two promises to give a
full glimpse into that Journey we got
this we're built for this our family
grows first Kylie now Chloe it's going
to be really exciting and I am ready I
think for every sister we have different
boundary levels and we all try to
respect that and probably moving forward
we might all have and like your
boundaries are allowed to change and
mine will probably change later but I'm
also I think a lot of us are you know
what is in the media is sort of things
that we feel we need to film because
it's in a way unfair to the viewers if
they don't get to see that and fans
should expect nothing different in
season two which premieres September
22nd on Hulu I wish we could have one
boring day in this family
[Music]
thank you